a main part of our discussion was the
regulation for the digital green
certificate and allow me to touch
briefly on it with this digital
certificate we
aim to help member states reinstate
the freedom of movement in a safe
responsible
and trusted manner we are now
two weeks before the end of the
first quarter since vaccination began
in the european union the good news is
that
we have made progress biontech pfizer
and moderna are delivering on their
contracts
but we also know that astrazeneca
has unfortunately under-produced
and under-delivered we know that
we can achieve our target to have 70 of
the adult population
fully vaccinated by the end of the
summer
and we know that deliveries will
increase in the second quarter
one more vaccine is approved and will
kick in that is johnson johnson
it will start in april now
if we have a look at the epidemiological
situation
it is getting worse and we know that we
need to
accelerate the vaccination rates and
this
is why we need to ensure that there
is reciprocity and proportionality
if the situation does not change we will
have to reflect on how to make
exports to vaccine producing countries
dependent on their level of openness
we will reflect on whether exports to
countries who have
higher vaccination rates than us
are still proportionate
you